parece que
sí buenas noches a todos los argentinos
de bien porque hoy comienza la
reconstrucción de
[Música]
Argentina y se hizo la luz queridos
amigos amigas la tormenta electoral
Argentina ha terminado y sabéis queé la
comunidad div visual política estaba en
lo cierto las casi 140,000 personas que
respondiste a nuestra pregunta electoral
lo clavaste mile sera el nuevo
presidente de la república Argentina y
no será por un margen precisamente
pequeño en la segunda vuelta el león
liberal ha reventado todos los
pronósticos y se ha hecho con casi el 5%
de los votos le ha sacado 11 puntos al
candidato peronista Sergio masa en estas
elecciones el peronismo ha tenido uno de
los peores resultados de toda su
historia al tiempo que milei se ha
convertido en el presidente con más
porcentaje de apoyo electoral desde el
regreso de la Democracia Ni más ni menos
que
1983 hoy la mayoría de los argentinos
celebran una victoria que traerá consigo
un histórico cambio de gobierno ahora sí
que sí de una forma u otra la argentina
se lanzará por un enorme tobogán del
cambio La promesa de mi ley es dar la
vuelta como un calcetín al modelo
económico y social del país gaucho
quiero decirle a todos los argentinos
que hoy comienza el fin de la decadencia
Argentina Hoy empezamos a dar vuelta a
la página de nuestra historia y volvemos
a retomar el camino que nunca deberíamos
haber perdido hoy se termina el modelo
empobrecedor del estado omnipresente que
solo beneficia a algunos mientras la
mayoría de los argentinos
sufren sin embargo queridos amigos y sin
querer aguaros la fiesta especialmente a
quienes nos veis desde el país del asado
el tango y el fútbol el entusiasmo por
la victoria puede durar más bien poco
Ahora toca hacerlo más difícil
enfrentarse a todos los problemas que
arrastra consigo la economía de este
país porque seamos claros Argentina no
necesita cambios cosméticos o pequeños
recortes Para nada la Argentina necesita
neces llevar a cabo urgentemente un
montón de reformas que afecten a
prácticamente todos los campos
económicos y sociales gasto público
legislación laboral regulaciones
apertura al exterior y un largo
larguísimo etcétera de materias
absolutamente imprescindibles que se
entienda bien la situación de Argentina
es crítica los cambios que nuestros país
necesita son drásticos no hay lugar para
gradualismo no hay lugar para la tibieza
no hay lugar para medias tintas Pues
bien estos que vamos a ver a
continuación son algunos de los grandes
retos con los que ahora Javier Miley se
tendrá que ver las caras pero amigos
amigas Si os parece empecemos la
historia por el principio arranquemos
viva la libertad Viva Viva la
libertad Viva Viva la libertad
viva Dios bendiga a los
argentinos Muchas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias
Buenos Aires la capital de la Argentina
es habitualmente descrita como la
capital de un imperio que nunca existió
y no es para menos esta hermosa ciudad
es el vivo reflejo de un vibrante pasado
que hoy deviene en una frustrante
nostalgia creo que ya todos lo sabéis
hacia finales del siglo XIX y principios
del siglo XX el país gaucho era una
tierra próspera y pujante que se codeaba
de tú a tú con las principales potencias
del mundo Incluyendo los mismísimos
estados unidos podemos decir que por
aquella época Argentina tenía su propia
visión del sueño americano y que por
aquellos tiempos los argentinos
acariciaban el cielo pero amigos amigas
durante el resto del siglo XX del cielo
se pasó al infierno Argentina Dejó de
ser una de las economías más vibrantes
del mundo para convertirse en una de las
más decadentes de todo el planeta ahora
año tras año el país no deja de perder
puestos en el ranking mundial Argentina
es uno de los pocos países del mundo que
está en vías no al desarrollo sino al
subdesarrollo al menos en términos
relativos cuando la Argentina entró al
siglo XX era el país más rico del mundo
Argentina tenía una de las monedas más
sólidas del mundo millones de
inmigrantes se agolpaban en nuestras
costas para poder tener la chance de un
futuro mejor éramos la envidia del mundo
sin embargo en un momento la clase
política decidió que la riqueza de los
argentinos no podía estar en manos de
los argentinos sino que tenía que estar
en las manos de ellos pero de todo esto
ya somos hablado un montón de veces aquí
en visual politic Así que hoy con este
vídeo nuestra intención es completamente
distinta queridos amigos amigas tras un
siglo XX repleto de golpes de estado y
gobiernos autoritarios el día 10 de
diciembre de 2023 se conmemora el 40
aniversario de la reinstauración
democrática ese mismo día Javier Miley
será investido presidente con unas
promesas de cambio tan grandes como los
titánicos problemas que padece Argentina
un país en el que por ahora la
prosperidad parece una meta inalcanzable
quiero ser muy claro con algo el modelo
de la decadencia ha llegado a su fin no
hay vuelta atrás aquí en visual politic
y también en visual economic ya os hemos
hablado de muchas de las promesas de mi
ley Pero ahora con la aplastante
victoria del candidato libertario han
surgido más preguntas Cuáles son los
principales obstáculos a los que se
enfrentará la Argentina para poder
volver a brillar Qué cosas tienen que
arreglar los argentinos y visto lo visto
con qué problemas tendrá que eliar mi
ley durante su presidencia Pues bien sin
más preámbulo busquemos ya las
respuestas a todas estas preguntas Óscar
todo
[Música]
tuyo una generación
acorralada lo primero que tenemos que
tener en cuenta para valorar el
potencial de Argentina es que estamos
hablando de un país de 45 millones de
habitantes que a diferencia de la mayor
parte de países occidentales sigue
siendo razonablemente joven de hecho
según estimaciones de las Naciones
Unidas durante la próxima década la
población joven de Argentina será la
mayor de toda su historia evidentemente
esto supone una gran ventaja pero claro
tampoco basta solo con tener gente joven
la clave de verdad está en si un país
como Argentina es o no capaz de
aprovechar ese potencial si realmente
tiene toda esa capacidad para explotar
El Talento joven y justo aquí es donde
las cosas dejan de pintar tamban bien de
entrada si bien la pobreza del país ha
rondado el 40% Durante los últimos 5
años esta se ha acentuado claramente
entre los más jóvenes para que os hais
una idea según los datos oficiales más
del 54 por de todos los niños y
adolescentes argentinos viven en
diciones de pobreza con todo lo que ello
conlleva por ejemplo el observatorio
argentinos por la educación ha realizado
un seguimiento detallado de las últimas
promociones de estudiantes titulados
tanto a nivel de Educación primaria como
de secundaria y sabéis qué los
resultados son
alarmantes en el 2016 cerca de 750,000
niños argentinos comenzaron la educación
primaria Y aunque el 922 por llegó a
terminarla en tiempo y forma solo el 43
por de todos estos estudiantes pasó a la
educación secundar aria con
conocimientos mínimos aceptables tanto
en lengua como en matemáticas y claro
todo esto acaba teniendo consecuencias
en cadena los estudiantes que terminan
la primaria sin conocimientos básicos
repiten el mismo patrón en la secundaria
un nivel educativo donde el panorama
argentino resulta simple y llanamente
desolador Y es que atentos a este dato
solo 13 de cada 100 estudiantes
argentinos que ingresan en la educación
secundaria la terminan en el tiempo
teórico estipulado y con los
conocimientos mínimos aceptables en
lengua y matemáticas solo 13 de cada 100
es un desastre gigantesco que muchos
expertos están definiendo ya como una
tragedia educativa sin precedentes siete
de cada 10 argentinos creen que la
educación Está peor que 30 años atrás y
que caerá aún más alerta por un informe
sobre educación en Argentina esto es una
tragedia silenciosa atentos a lo que
decía este editorial del diario La
Nación el día 28 de junio de 2023
Educación una emergencia impostergable
reconocer la emergencia del sistema
educativo nacional en todos los niveles
y modalidades es el primer paso el
problema es que los cambios educativos
son terriblemente lentos incluso Aunque
de repente se pudiera reformar todo el
modelo educativo de arriba a abajo los
resultados tardarían un montón de años
en llegar y además por el camino es
probable que se quedara perdida toda una
generación y claro todo eso suponiendo
que consiga sacar adelante un cambio
educativo integral porque si no vamos
mal los resultados educativos de
Argentina van de mal en peor
[Música]
fijaos en pantalla podéis ver como en
Las evaluaciones realizadas por la
UNESCO sobre capacidad de comprensión
lectora Argentina es el segundo país con
peor evolución solo la supera por la
baja Guatemala y mientras tanto otros
países como Perú Brasil o Paraguay
lograron importantes avances Y eso que
solo hablamos de 2019 todo apunta a que
con el Terrible desempeño de Argentina
durante la pandemia de la covid-19 hoy
las cosas son aún peor mucho peor así
que ya lo veis las nuevas generaciones
parecen acorraladas por un lado sufren
un sistema educativo que cada vez es
peor viven mayoritariamente con unas
condiciones muy precarias la pobreza
infantil y juvenil no deja de crecer y
luego para colmo a medida que van
cerrando su etapa académica se dan de
bruces con una economía que también va
de mal en peor así que qué queréis que
os diga en cierto modo es muy probable
que esto sea lo que explique por qué los
jóvenes se han echado masivamente en
brazos de la apuesta rupturista de
Javier
Miley y por supuesto todo esto que os
estamos contando tiene importantes
implicaciones no solo sociales y
políticas sino también económicas una
escasa y pobre formación equivale a
mucha menos productividad y justo en un
momento en el que la Argentina lo que
necesita es precisamente mejorar mucho
en este parámetro aunque ya veis que en
lugar de eso lo que vemos es una especie
de espiral destructiva sea como sea y a
pesar de eso vamos a quedarnos con la
mejor cara Argentina tendrá un aluvión
de jóvenes disponibles para poner en
marcha su nuevo motor económico
Simplemente hay que conseguir que todos
esos jóvenes de una forma u otra puedan
ponerse manos a la obra por lo que dicho
esto Ahora pasemos a otro problema muy
relacionado además con este que hemos
visto está la industria Argentina
preparada para competir Hasta qué punto
puede la actual matriz productiva
liderar el el cambio bien Vamos a
[Música]
verlo Los Rehenes de la
industria queridos amigos amigas aquí en
visual politic ya hemos visto en pasados
vídeos la par particular relación o
mejor dicho fobia que el peronismo
mantiene hacia el comercio exterior
ambos se llevan peor que los perros y
los gatos el proteccionismo en Argentina
está tan arraigado que es uno de los
pocos países del mundo que de hecho
castiga las exportaciones y desde luego
Durante los gobiernos kisneristas esta
filosofía económica ha encontrado su
particular
paraíso como podes ver en pantalla los
diferentes gobiernos argentinos llevan
años tomando medidas para restringir
cada vez más el comercio internacional y
aislar a la Argentina del resto del
mundo tan solo Durante los primeros dos
años de macri se produjo una cierta
liberalización muy suave casi
imperceptible el resto del tiempo
Barrera al comercio licencias trámites
permisos aranceles y todo tipo de
limitaciones tanto para importar como
para exportar argentina se ha convertido
en un sinónimo de alergia a la libre
movilidad de bienes servicios y
capitales y la pregunta es Pero por qué
demonios el estado argentino es tan
estricto con este tema de qué les sirve
limitar tanto los flujos comerciales de
entrada y salida del país no se supone
acaso que exportar es bueno para que las
Industrias y las empresas argentinas
puedan
crecer
Pues el problema queridos amigos es que
en este país el tango de la lógica se
baila al ritmo de la querida amada y
Ultra protegida industria nacional basta
ver como los países más
desarrollados protegen a sus
trabajadores a sus industrias y a sus
productores con lo cual pasa a ser un
importantísimo actor el estado nacional
en mantener la competitividad de la
industria mantener la competitividad de
eh la actividad económica seguirá siendo
objetivo de nuestro gobierno que la
industria nacional vuelva a ocupar un
lugar preponderante dentro de la
economía Argentina y es que veréis buena
parte del liario peronista en materia
económica se ciñe a dos principios el
consumo y la producción nacional
básicamente les encantaría vivir en una
especie de autarquía puede parecer
extraño en el mundo globalizado en el
que vivimos pero en Argentina Esta es la
forma de pensar de buena parte de la
clase política sino de la inmensa
mayoría y como se dice en el país gaucho
para muestra basta un botón
fijaos La idea es que la industria
nacional no tenga que competir con
bienes producidos en otras partes del
mundo lo que supuestamente pues protege
trabajos y también ese concepto que
algunos denominan el orgullo de la
soberanía económica todo un relato que
al final no hace sino mantener un modelo
de empresas poco competitivas falta de
oportunidades retrasos tecnológicos y
altísimos costes echemos un vistazo por
ejemplo a la industria textil una de las
más protegidas de todo el aparato
productivo de la Argentina en lo que
respecta a la carga tributaria por
sectores los mayores impuestos recaen
sobre las importaciones de indumentaria
cuyo arancel de importación promedio es
del 35 por al que hay que sumar el 7 y
medio del impuesto país y 3% de tasa
estadística para llegar a un impuesto
total del
45,5 por. Y qué supone esto Pues veréis
creo que por todos es ampliamente
conocido el grave problema que Argentina
tiene con la inflación de ahí
precisamente el plan de dolarización que
tiene Miley y sobre el que ya os hemos
hablado en varios vídeos en nuestro
canal hermano visual economic Por cierto
si aún no lo conoces No esperes más
tenéis el enlace en la descripción El
caso es que si miramos de cerca Cómo se
comportan los precios de los sectores
protegidos podemos encontrar una
tendencia bastante
curiosa como podéis ver mientras que la
inflación crece de forma más o menos
cente el precio de la ropa Es
tremendamente volátil como si los flujos
comerciales de este producto cambiaran
drásticamente de precios de la noche a
la mañana y la pregunta es por qué rayos
ocurre esto Pues básicamente porque el
estado argentino no protege industrias
de buenas a primeras sino que lo hace a
cambio de firmar acuerdos de precios que
luego le permite a los políticos
justificar más controles sobre la
economía acuerdo de precios con el
sector de indumentaria este
entendimiento presentado por el ministro
de economía Sergio masa y el secretario
de comercio Matías tombolini garantiza
la estabilidad de los precios de más de
50 marcas de indumentaria que estarán
disponibles en todo el territorio
nacional en locales propios de las
firmas es una especie de juego que
consiste en algo así el gobierno dice
venga yo te protejo de las importaciones
pero a cambio acordamos unos precios y
unos márgenes de ganancia y sabéis que
los picos y los balles del gráfico
responden justamente al vencimiento y la
renovación de esos acuerdos al final los
argentinos pierden pero por el camino
los políticos sacan pecho y los
empresarios cercanos al gobierno evitan
la competencia Claro que en ocasiones la
dinámica pasa de ser un romántico relato
de soberanía económica a una oscura
trama de chantaje porque cuando la cosa
se pone fea el estado rápidamente
amenaza con abrir la economía Sergio
masa amenazó con abrir la importación de
ropa Si no frenan los aumentos
desmesurados de precios pero pese a todo
aunque pueda resultar paradójico lo
cierto Es que la libertad de competencia
es algo a lo que muchas empresas
argentinas le tienen auténtico pavor
mucho más incluso que al gobierno y por
supuesto No solo hablamos de la
industria textil sino también del sector
Automotriz la industria electrónica o la
del caucho y el plástico entre otras
muchas Y esto es algo que lleva pasando
ya desde hace mucho pero que muchísimo
tiempo la unión Industrial Argentina le
pide más protección a
Cristina titular de la unión Industrial
Argentina reclama al gobierno más
medidas proteccionistas todo esto
queridos amigos es lo que se ha venido a
conocer como empresarios prendarios es
decir empresarios que vien básicamente
del
[Música]
gobierno sus empresas no son las más
productivas No son particularmente
eficientes no son innovadoras pero pesa
todo persisten muchas veces ni siquiera
se machacan por producir a pleno
rendimiento total para qué De hecho los
sectores más protegidos de la industria
Argentina tienen tasa de uso de su
capacidad Industrial menores que las del
promedio del país en resumen que el
sector productivo argentino tampoco está
preparado para aprovechar la nueva
oleada de jóvenes que está llegando al
mercado laboral y el problema de hecho
es incluso mayor pensadlo bien Si de
repente todo este modelo de
proteccionismo cayera es muy probable
que muchas empresas argentinas quebraran
las transiciones rara vez son fáciles
hay que hacerlas Es indispensable pero
hay que saber que pueden ser duras muy
duras dicho esto queridos amigos Todavía
nos falta por ver un último elemento
clave en toda esta historia
atentos
pueden todos ponerse la
[Música]
10 efectivamente Lo acabamos de ver en
Argentina no se aprovecha intensamente
el capital humano ni tampoco existe una
matriz empresarial que sea productiva
innovadora y capaz de competir en
mercados abiertos Aunque Por supuesto
Siempre hay excepciones De todas formas
Más allá del capital humano y de las
empresas qué ocurre con las
instituciones pues desgraciadamente en
Argentina reina un electoralismo feroz
un electoralismo que está por encima de
cualquier cosa incluso del propio
país sin ir más lejos la campaña
presidencial del 2023 ha sido una de las
más polarizadas y acaloradas de toda la
historia Argentina para masa milei era
una amenaza violenta de extrema derecha
dispuesta a destruir las instituciones
del país mientras que para Miley su
adversario condenaría al país a una
eterna hambruna y miseria es el momento
de preguntarnos Si queremos seguir
transitando este sendero decadente que
hace que cada día seamos más miserables
que tengamos cada vez más pobres que
tengamos más
indigentes donde los chicos se tienen
que ir del país para buscar un futuro
hemos un país condenado a la miseria
quiero ser presidente además entendiendo
que hay algunos que ni siquiera me votan
convencidos sino simplemente como
vehículo para no elegir un camino que es
violencia que es odio es daño a 40 años
el clima político de la Argentina no
parece el mejor el nuevo presidente
viene con una agenda bajo el brazo que
promete reconstruir el país de arriba a
abajo La pregunta es logrará mi ley
sacarlo adelante y Establecer un nuevo
Marco narrativo que domine la política
Argentina de las próximas
décadas ahora la llegada de Javier Miley
a la Primera Plana de la política
Argentina Abre una puerta a una enorme
revolución de tener un Banco Central que
ahoga el acceso al Dólar e imprime pesos
a lo loco a dolarizar la economía de
cerrarse comercialmente al mundo a
prometer echar abajo todas esas barreras
de nacionalizar empresas a privatizar
lasas todo esto es quizá una Revolución
necesaria pero será capaz de generar un
consenso político más amplio en torno a
las reformas quiero decirle a todos los
argentinos y a todos los dirigentes
políticos que todos aquellos que quieran
sumarse a la Nueva Argentina serán
bienvenidos no importa de dónde vengan
No importa que hayan hecho antes no
importa Qué diferencia tengamos Estoy
seguro que es más importante lo que nos
une que los que nos separa porque eso es
lo que va a serc que pongamos de pie a
la patria y volvamos a ser una
potencia ojo Esto no es ninguna tontería
los países con más éxito económico
suelen compartir una premisa todas sus
fuerzas políticas relevantes han estado
comprometidas con los fundamentos clave
del modelo económico es decir los
diferentes gobiernos de los países
exitosos han mantenido el rumbo de la
nave solo con ligeras variaciones y para
eso hace falta un claro consenso
político si no hay un acuerdo
mayoritario pronto puede llegar otro
gobierno a la casa rosada para darle
otro manotazo al timón desde un punto de
vista político esto es particularmente
tentador si la transición del modelo se
hace más dura de lo previsto por lo que
la pregunta es lo conseguirá Javier
Miley si lo logra Argentina lo tiene
todo para volver a brillar es un país
joven la extensa región de la Pampa
sigue siendo una tierra muy fértil y el
país tiene un montón de recursos
naturales de todo tipo incluyendo por
supuesto petróleo gas y l tío a dicho
Todo esto ahora las preguntas son para
vosotros creéis que Argentina volverá a
despegar logrará mi ley labrar un
consenso amplio en torno a las reformas
pues amigos como siempre podéis dejarnos
vuestras respuestas en los comentarios y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante No olvides darle al like
suscríbete a visual politics si quieres
ver los siguientes vídeos Y como siempre
nos vemos en el próximo un saludo y
hasta
[Música]
pronto